こんにちは...
はじめしゃちょーです...
ハァー
ちょっとすみませんちょっと
テンションが低いというか
こう、何と言えばいいのか分からない
複雑な心境になっております
あのー、皆さんご存知の通り
僕、結構不規則な生活してます
一睡もしない日とかが結構あったり、食生活がめちゃくちゃだったり
あ、自炊しないのも原因です
色々ちょっとYoutuberになってからですね
ちょっとぶっ飛んだ生活が続いておりまして
ちょっととある機会がありまして
をさせていただきました
まあ、体に異常がないかという意味も込めて
ちょっと結果を見てみて最近来たんですけれども
いやー…
あの、僕基本的に健康な人間なんですよ
いままで健康診断とかいろいろやってきても
どれも基本的にこう、なんか
元気です！
って言われてきたんすよ
今回初めてちょっと
初めてちょっとまずいぞと
いうことをいただきました
なんかこういうの数値言ったらちょっと怖いんで、
なんか「見せるな」ってマミーにも言われたんで見せないんですけど
はい、というわけで
えー
みたいです、おめで…
おめでとうじゃないや
おめでとうじゃ
ないよ！
中性脂肪ってのに僕ちょっと今、異常があるみたいです
高いほうでね
いやぁもうね、
すっごい
すっごいすっごい
すっごいすっごいすっっっっ
すっごいすっごいすっっっっごい、
すごい…なんか
心当たりがあるんですけども、
心当たりがありすぎて逆にわかんない
中性脂肪とはですね
まあ、脂質代謝異常。脂肪の代謝かな？？
脂質の代謝の異常で食事の影響などによって
増減するみたいです
（ヤベーーーー…）
（心当たりしか）
（ないぜ★）
なんかさ、血液検査とかでやばいですとかさ
そういうの言われたの初めてだったから
割とね、ちょっと…なんかちゃんと
ご飯とかしようって思いましたね
あー、なんか色々書いてありますね
中性脂肪とは、
あ、高いならいいじゃんw
え！待って、高いならいいじゃん！
要するに身体を動かすエネルギー値が高いってことでしょ？
もはや高エネルギー反応持ってるぜこれ
ご飯を食べることによって取得された脂質ですね
脂質が小腸から吸収されて血液中に入り
生命維持活動に使われていって残ったものが
蓄えられたのが中性脂肪
あ、じゃあエネルギー…蓄え過ぎてそれが余っちゃったのかな
その余ったのが中性脂肪らしいです
んー、な、何だろ、なんか
エネルギー有り余ってますみたいな感じかなぁ？
アリアナグランデ（？）
え、待って、１５０を超えると…
え、どんぐらいだっけ
え？待って、やばいじゃん！
え、待って！
やばい！待って待って待
やばい、なんかや、なんか嫌な気がしてきた
僕今、い…
医者からの生活習慣や食事の内容などの
らしいです。
んぁ〜まあ、いつか来ると思ってましたよ
この食生活、たぶん皆さんが想像してる以上にぶっ飛んでますよ
中性脂肪を下げるためには
３つのことをしなきゃいけないみたいです
ひとつ！
飲酒してる場合は禁酒する
お酒はそんなに飲まないからぁ
たぶんこれはしなくていいです
ふたつ！
肥満・運動不足の場合は運動の習慣を始める
そう。なんかね、そう、そうそう、そうよ！
そうや！
そうやねん…
最近ね、なんかやたらとバスケットしに行ってるのは
実はちょっと運動不足過ぎてやばいなと思って
最近ちょっとバスケットとかね
運動なるべくするように
心がけているとこあります
これはもう、クリア。
みっつめ！
を控えた食事を摂る
これは無理です。
いや、そういうこと言ってられねぇわ
そういうこと言ってられないんだよね～
炭水化物系は控えたほうがいいのかもしれないすね
でもそんな太ってるわけでもないんですよね
動かなさすぎなのかもしれない
中性脂肪が高いとこの後僕はどうなるか！？
というお話なんですけども
中性脂肪値が高い人は血の粘りが強くドロドロになります
そうすると血管が詰まりやすくなる
えー
で、なんか流れにくい血をこう身体が頑張って流してるから
血管に負担がかかって
ひぁー
で、このままいくと僕は、あのー
心臓に血液が通りにくくなって、その、なんか
締め付けられる痛みが出てきたり
ですね、または
ですね
脳の血管で血が止まっちゃって、神経麻痺になったりするらしいです…
あーーやばい、ついに来たかぁ
今までちょっとてきとーにぅぅぅ若さで乗り切ってたとこもあるんですけども
ついに！
崩れてきたぞ。
ラーメンこんだけ食うような変食してたり
まあお菓子の食べ過ぎとかも結構ダメだと思いますよ
カロリー的にも
はい、というわけでですね、ちょっとねー
血液検査の結果で僕はちょっと割とやべぇ状況だということに気付いてしまいました
今後は！
食生活をちゃんとできればいいなと思ってます
まず自炊しよう！
自炊するかいい嫁を連れてくるしかない！！本当
いやぁ結構あの健康診断とかさぁ
血液検査でちょっとやばいですって言われたら
結構グッときますよ
ちゃんとお菓子も控えます！！
だから！ぉ…逆に考えたらさ、
おいらこのタイミングでラーメン禁止にしててかなり正解だったと思いますよ
いやまじこれラーメン続けてたらおいらマジぽっくり逝ってたで
なるべくちょっと油っぽいものとかも控えて
運動多めで
お菓子もちょっとね、極力我慢しながら
あーさっきグミチョコ食べちゃった
グータラ生活してる君！！
経験者は語るぞ、マジでちゃんとご飯食べたほうがいい。
じゃあな！
命がけのじゃあな
（ED）